[Musique]
bonjour johan dodo ou jouer tout le
temps président du cercle démocratique
de la martinique conseiller municipal
d'opposition au lamentin et depuis peu
candidat à la députation dans le centre
atlantique le centre atlantique et
première circonscription comment
expliquer j'ai un goût doux comment
expliquer que cette circonscription
fascine autant qu'elle soit autant
convoité
monsieur bah moi je pense que depuis
l'annoncé d'air que de marie gillain
effectivement ya beaucoup de personnes
qui souhaitent se présenter
pour ma part c'est une candidature
normale et courante puisque rappelez
vous qu'en 2012
j'étais candidat avec les matières que
en tant que soutien mais pour mace
induit aussi une équipe dont la nature
reste valide en 2014
j'ai pu assister aux municipales aux
veaux du jeu continue le combat la
mission de faire passer mes idées et
j'espère les faire passer huit candidats
déjà 8
ça paraît beaucoup c'est pas moi ce que
je sais c'est que 2010 est symbolise le
vêtement diversion de l'action
parlementaire d'afrique marie jeanne est
ce que je trouve quand même assez
dommage pour lui c'est que
malheureusement les mâles et les maris
janice pas intéressés que c'est comme ça
que je les appelle ont oublié de mettre
en avant l'action de ce grand monsieur
de la politique martiniquaise qui mieux
que quand même que ses amis le maître
pendant en tout cas mettre en avant son
action parlementaire
c'est pas mal vous annoncez votre
candidature rendant d'abord hommage
alfred marie-jeanne de sortant qui ne se
représente pas lorsqu'un homme se
présente en politique il mène le combat
souvent au détriment de sa famille de sa
profession ou autre et malheureusement
les gens ne le voient pas assez de
milice est vingtième année que quelqu'un
a acheté des députés c'était le 12 juin
97 si je me rappelle bien voulu fait des
yeux doux la noce pas des yeux doux
allez je vous rappelle qu'il soutient
fabrice lesjongard son nom propre
laissez moi vous dire que tu es quelque
chose un homme politique lorsqu'il va
aux élections doit pas à temps
d'avoir l'aval des discours y présenter
aux élections je considère que les
personnes qui font cela ce sont des
personnes qui essaient de monter sur les
épaules de ce monsieur
pour essayer de sortir la tête de l'eau
et moi je combats ses personnages quand
on vend politique avec sa force créative
de séduction de votre part en face à des
experts en politique il faut respecter
toutes les personnes qui s'engagent et
qui vont élections rappelez-vous j'étais
candidat en 2014 face à pierre samot qui
était le le plaisancier j'étais le plus
jeune aujourd'hui des personnes
considèrent que je suis conseiller
municipal d'opposition
je considère que je suis un élu tout
court lorsque les choses ne vont pas je
dis qu'elles ne vont pas je dis comment
j'estime qu'il faudrait les régler et
des fois je me propose même à faire des
actions pour montrer que c'est possible
si vous vous montrez connu et on parle
de députés d'ailleurs un député doit
être en mesure de travail et d'échangés
avec tout le monde
un député de l homme de clan il doit
être l'homme de toute la population
martiniquaise
ce n'est pas le slogan d'apple morigène
s'est fait un constat de vérité quelque
part j'avais coché fabrice du nom l'un
de vos concurrents pour cette
circonscription
je n'ai pas le concurrent g que les
amygdales et aux familles je pense qu'on
verra où on voit en angola la fin de
cette élection c'est quelqu'un de doué
mais génie quand même ce que j'ai à dire
lorsque son élection
c'est sous son nom si on espère son
attendant valant x ou de y aller pour
bacall alors toi galets en tout cas il y
a de bons nombres josette manin en
premier lieu
josette manin ancien président du
conseil général la seule femme à avoir
occupé de telles fonctions quelque part
en y allant vous risquez pas de de gêner
un petit peu cette martinique qui avant
ce qui pourrait désigner cette première
femme parlementaire de vous dis ok
quelque chose le sel démocratique a
toujours appelé l'ensemble des femmes a
pu vous en 2012 cinéma tient à 4,26 et
maquettes aux élections il n'y a pas
attendu que d'autres femmes nous nous
nous le disent et diane connaît maya pas
et pour les jeunes nous étions tous les
jeunes monique à se présenter aux
élections avec foi et détermination
basé sur un socle qui qu'est-ce que ceux
soutenus par trois piliers la sagesse de
leur pensée la force de la conviction et
la beauté de l'opposition et de nos
actions pour le développement du
territoire et la martinique et c'est
comme ça que nous allons aux élections
de philosophie et sagesse quelle est
votre vision juin goudou de la fonction
de député hier soir encore nous avons
organisé sur cette circonscription
une rencontre pour pour débattre pour
vous le député doit faire croire
exactement le député doit pas être
réduit à la construction d'une oie à un
amendement ni à poser des questions
orales ou écrites en session
parlementaire
il doit être au plus près de la
population et travaille avec l'ensemble
de la société civile en politique ne
peut pas tout maîtriser ne peut pas tout
connaître
il doit être entouré des bonnes
personnes et avoir ce réseau assez
important des fois quand j'entends des
gens me dire qu'il qu'il faut faire
partie de grands partis politiques pour
faire passer ses idées c'est soit on a
les couilles je peux aller sont à la
force pour clore l'histoire
les couilles et la force pour y aller et
faire passer ses idées seront les a pas
encore une fois sage est la philosophie
et le cru quand on est grand on sait
pourquoi on y va on ne va pas pour
rigoler d'accord ça n'a pas été le cas
pour les parlementaires
jusqu'à aujourd'hui qu'il faut se poser
la question d'opération martiniquaise
moi je signe mans d'ailleurs ils nous
assurent qu'ils soient censés durer de
18 heures à minuit au restaurant le
thibault on a fini à minuit parce qu'on
voit c'est sûr des discussions sur le
parking parce que cet airbus le parking
parce que parce qu'il ya une attente une
vraie attendre l'opération qui espère
que demain matin
nous députés comprendront enfin que nous
éduquons prendront enfin qu'on peut pas
faire du n'importe quoi comme à
augmenter les impôts comme comme cela
vous parlez d'une communauté
d'agglomération c'est pas un député qui
désire non mais non parce qu'il ya un
comportement avoir de la part des élus
on ne fait pas du n'importe quoi dans le
cadre de service public on ne laisse pas
des enfants sans manger dans le sud est
venu nous dire que c'est parce que les
retards et j'en avais parlé du sud la
forêt dense et xla menti ni la mort ni
comme une histoire de centre de fort de
france de l'aude au sud quand on est
député
c'est pour l'ensemble ou la martinique
et des territoires en vie ou non
alors on comprend bien que vous allez
privilégier le contact sur le terrain
pour bien ressentir les choses ou bien
comprendre l'aspect les aspirations des
martiniquais
mais savent que nous sommes à 7000 km et
qu'on reproche beaucoup parlementaires
de nos pays de ne pas être suffisamment
présents à l'assemblée nationale ou en
commission pourra refaire le travail
rédigé les lois par exemple exemple
exact à qui on aurait fait l'une de nos
méthodes
d'ailleurs c'est de dire que lorsqu'on
vous élections c'est un diu un titulaire
et un suppléant
le député doit être en permanence à
l'assemblée nationale pour faire avancer
des dossiers il faut arrêter de faire
croire à la population martiniquaise
qu'il faut être meilleur et puis député
pour connaître les problématiques
aujourd'hui internet alors qu'aucun
peuple animé le pagne avion à lausanne
il faut une équipe qui travaille avec
vous et qui vous fasse sur de fausses
excuses vieillissement mais bien sûr
comment voulez vous faire passer des
dossiers faire avancer les choses
si vous n'avez pas un bisou important au
sein du parlement que c'est impossible
donc c'est très précis de grands groupes
nous non vous pouvez faire partie d'un
bâtiment est assez influent en est il de
la famille qui est directement marie
jeanne et miller qui font partie de
groupes moins importants tandis que la
république parce que pourquoi
pour preuve les députés qui sont les qui
travaillent le plus ne sont pas
forcément ceux qui font partie des gogos
commence à mener votre campagne dans
cette circonscription prévu quand même
les noms qui circulent en appareils de
josette manin de fabrice du nom
également
karine rousseau qui se montrent beaucoup
avec ses fonctions de président du
comité martiniquais du tourisme et de
conseillers rassembler de martinique il
ya raphaël vaugirard lee attrition
verneuil la marine sur elie beaucoup de
noms beaucoup de noms et pour occuper
cet espace comment vous ferez vous la
ssup sur les afters rock bien beau mais
monsieur que vous m'avez si tu sais qui
tu es candidate en 2012
quelques années dans des milices
démissionner oui j'ai toujours su faire
campagne tranquillement avec sagesse
calme une passion et quelques beaux crus
parfois de 30 ans et petrov c'est votre
saison mais ça fait partie de la vie
politique ça fait parler avec politique
mais en tout cas mon travail paiera
donc est ce que c'est de la campagne
chez page travaillent au quotidien sur
le terrain la population seul à faire
valoir au moment voulu
cet engagement vous avez certainement
remarqué que la population est de plus
en plus réticente en regardant les
politiques vous avez toujours prenait
justement l'implication des jeunes dans
la campagne est ce que vous avez
l'impression aujourd'hui que six jeunes
à vivre encore entendre tout ce bois
politique parce que cette initiative
quand même il y aura une présidentielle
auparavant on parle déjà des
sénatoriales je n'ai pas un peu
brouillée ce que je vois un gars sur le
terrain ce que même si beaucoup de
jeunes ne se manifestent pas encore ils
suivent énormément ce qui se passe sur
tout le passage de donald trump l'a
montré en tout cas le la montrions vous
de nous faire croire que marine le pen
serait à un niveau de jeu très élevé
donc tout le monde suit je pense qu'ils
se mobiliseront le moment venu vous
unique et son sont intéressés par la
chose politique même s'ils ne seront pas
forcément aux urnes à m'écouter
convoquant le nombre de personnes qui
étaient dante dans la future rocade y
reçoit on a terminé à minuit j'ai
beaucoup d'espoir parce qu'il n'est pas
que dès qu'une personne y avait une
majorité de jeunes de tous types de
quartier et les discussions étaient
vraiment riche et cela m'a vraiment fait
plaisir
l'afterwork par définition c'est après
le travail mais par exemple les
personnes âgées comment vous ferez votre
oeuvre campagne vaut mieux par email à
yop annie facebook spanish championship
à nice où le tient au quotidien merci
d'avoir été ce matin avec nogent godoy
rappelle que vous êtes président du
cercle démocratique de la martinique
également candidat à la députation dans
le centre atlantique vous êtes le
huitième candidat remercie mélodies